.
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
Wenn ich an meine Schulzeit,
an mein letztes Schuljahr denke:
Das war sicher nicht
die einfachste Zeit für mich.
Auch für meine Mutter nicht.
Für niemanden,
der damals mit mir zu tun hatte.
Ich hätte auch
einiges besser machen können.
Das ist weder der Anfang noch
das Ende von John Bürkis Geschichte.
Als Jugendlicher tickte er nicht so,
wie es Eltern und Schulbehörde
verlangten.
Schlussendlich stand er da,
ohne Schulabschluss.
So endete der Film,
den ich 2011 über John gedreht hatte.
Wie sieht sein Leben heute aus?
Davon handelt diese Reportage.
Der zwölf Jahre alte Film
über John
ist noch immer Thema
an verschiedenen Schulen.
Heute ist er Gast in einer Abschluss-
klasse im sankt-gallischen Buchs.
Wer sucht heute
noch eine Lehrstelle?
Hebt mal kurz die Hand.
Ich erhalte halt viele Absagen.
Jawohl.
- Und ehrlich: Das kackt mich an.
Ich gebe mir Mühe
mit den Bewerbungen.
Ja ...
Die Klasse hat viele Fragen an John.
Lehrerin Michaela Tarnutzer
sammelte sie und trägt sie vor.
"Wenn du
zurück an die Oberstufe könntest:
Was würdest du anders machen?"
Ich glaube,
ich würde alles anders machen.
Ich war nicht wirklich bereit dafür.
Ich war in der Schule, aber
mir ging anderes durch den Kopf.
Dinge, die aus heutiger Sicht
weniger wichtig sind.
Aber die beschäftigten mich damals.
Und ...
Dadurch habe ich wohl nie
ein grosses Interesse an der Schule
oder am Lernen, an Prüfungen
entwickelt.
Die meisten Prüfungen, auch wenn sie
nicht sehr anspruchsvoll waren,
verhaute ich.
Heute denke ich:
"Ich musste es nicht mal verstehen."
"Es hätte gereicht,
Fleiss zu investieren
und ein paar Dinge
auswendig zu lernen."
Ich verhaute zu viele davon
und kriegte darum schlechte Noten.
Ich bin in der Nähe von Uster
aufgewachsen ...
Blenden wir zurück.
Der 16-jährige John kehrt
nach einem mehrwöchigen Time-out
zurück in die Sekundarklasse
im aargauischen Birr.
Wie fühlt es sich an, anstatt zur
Arbeit wieder zur Schule zu kommen?
Ich bin schon froh,
wieder hier zu sein.
Ins Time-out musste er
aufgrund zahlreicher Verstösse
gegen die Schulordnung.
Ich bin erleichtert,
nicht mehr arbeiten zu müssen.
Also, noch nicht.
- Warum bist du erleichtert?
Ich bin einfach froh,
weil ich nicht mehr
so einen langen Schulweg habe.
Und weil ich in der Wärme
sitzen kann und konsumieren darf.
Im Unterricht
ist John nicht ganz bei der Sache.
Raffi, zieh dir die Werbung rein:
"Männer werden nie erwachsen,
nur ihre Spielzeuge teurer."
Der ist gut.
Wir steigen in die Pause ein.
John bleibt bitte noch schnell hier.
Sein Verhalten
störe den Klassengeist,
sagt Lehrerin Susanne Tschamper.
Einmal mehr redet sie
dem Jugendlichen ins Gewissen.
John, du setzt dich
sicher nicht auf den Tisch.
Ja.
Du setzt dich an den Tisch.
Also, John,
wir müssen ein Gespräch führen.
Wie schon öfters in letzter Zeit.
Du weisst, was wir von dir erwarten.
- Ja.
Was du machen kannst,
sind Selbstverständlichkeiten
wie Aufgaben machen
und pünktlich hier sein.
Bist du dir bewusst, dass du
dich auf einem Grat befindest?
Okay, ich gebe mir Mühe.
- Hand drauf, John. Okay?
Wir setzen uns heute in einer Woche
wieder zusammen und ziehen Bilanz.
Okay?
- Jep.
John möchte Grafiker lernen.
Doch mit schlechten Schulnoten eine
Lehrstelle zu finden, ist schwierig.
Bisher reiht sich Absage an Absage.
Um seine Chancen zu vergrössern,
bewirbt er sich
als Detailhandelsverkäufer.
Das ist für ihn
keine Herzensangelegenheit.
Dementsprechend hält sich
seine Motivation in Grenzen.
Mit wem schreibst du jetzt?
Mit einem Freund aus Frick,
den ich mal
in den Sommerferien kennenlernte.
Wir kennen uns
bereits zwei, drei Jahre.
Machst du das immer parallel
zum Bewerbungsschreiben?
Nicht immer, aber wenn ich mal ...
... am Schreibtisch sitze,
lasse ich das nebenbei laufen.
Bist du dann nicht unkonzentriert?
Das denken viele.
Aber ich kann auch Musik hören
und Hausaufgaben machen oder lernen.
Nein,
das ist eine Nebenbeschäftigung.
Dann bin ich online und weiss,
wer wann wo hingeht.
Zur gleichen Zeit
im Wohnzimmer nebenan.
Johns Stiefvater Zoran Sekalec
schaut sich eine DVD an.
Es ist einfach fantastisch,
das zu sehen.
Die Aufzeichnung
zeigt eine Massenveranstaltung
einer ungarischen Freikirche,
bei der auch der Kroate Mitglied ist.
Ich sehe mir den Film
immer wieder an.
Es macht mich
richtig leidenschaftlich.
Das begeistert mich.
Christliche Werte will Sekalec
auch seinem Stiefsohn vermitteln,
und dazu eine Anleitung
zum beruflichen Erfolg.
Hoi, John. Schau,
ich habe hier etwas aufgeschrieben.
Lies das mal!
Wir lesen ja
das Buch "Georg" miteinander.
Georg ist ein Student.
Das weisst du, wir lesen es ja.
Er weiss auch nicht, was er will.
Du hast ja nicht lange Zeit.
Nächstes Jahr ist fertig mit Schule
und du brauchst eine Lehrstelle.
Die Sanduhr läuft.
Die wichtigen Fragen sind:
"Was macht mir Freude?"
"Wo liegen
meine einzigartigen Stärken?"
"Was will ich
in meinem Leben erreichen?"
Frag dich das immer wieder selber.
Ja, bleib an der Sache dran.
Das Ganze mit der Lehrstelle
ist interessant.
Das ist halt ein Prozess.
Ist es okay,
wenn ich später rausgehe?
Bevor er raus darf, gibt es
noch ein gemeinsames Abendessen.
Mutter Joelma Sekalec arbeitet
als Kundenassistentin in einer Bank.
Die gebürtige Brasilianerin ist
für den Familienunterhalt zuständig.
Ihr Ehemann verdient ein Zubrot
als Zeitungsverträger.
Der ehemalige Personalberater
gab seinen Vollzeitjob auf,
um sich mehr
mit dem Glauben auseinanderzusetzen.
Die Entschlossenheit,
der Ehrgeiz ...
Ich wünsche mir, dass das
mehr aus Eigenantrieb passiert.
Das wäre genial, aber ...
- Dass er z.B. mal kommt und sagt:
"Zoran, ich habe
zwei Bewerbungen geschrieben."
Ohne dass wir etwas sagen müssen.
Dass es wirklich ...
Von ihm aus. Das wäre wirklich gut.
Ihr findet, ich sei in diesem gut,
hätte Talent für jenes
und sollte mal das ausprobieren
oder dort und dort
einen Sprachaufenthalt machen ...
Das ist das Thema des Potenzials.
Für uns ist das so klar.
- Ja.
Ja, für euch.
- Das muss ihm bewusst werden.
Das kann man nicht kommunizieren.
Ich mache den Detailhandelsfachmann
nur, damit ich etwas habe.
Danach schaue ich weiter, was
Grafiker oder Polygraf anbelangt.
Das ist das, was ich gut kann
und jeden Tag machen will.
Vor der Abschlussklasse im
sankt-gallischen Buchs erzählt John,
wie er damals
das Familienleben empfand.
Ihr habt das mit dem Stiefvater
ja mitgekriegt.
Das war für mich
auch nicht so einfach.
Ich fühlte mich damals so,
als würde ich fremdbestimmt.
Als ...
Sobald ich zu Hause war,
war ich unter Kontrolle.
Das sah man auch in der Szene,
als er ins Zimmer kam.
Er meinte das eigentlich gut
und wollte mir
mit den sieben Schritten zeigen,
wie ich meine Lehrstelle finde.
Ich war nicht empfänglich dafür.
Das mit den Hausaufgaben
war speziell:
Ich kam nach Hause und sah,
dass ich nicht allein war.
Was machte ich? Ich stellte alles
hin und traf mich mit Leuten.
Ich war einfach
nicht gerne zu Hause.
Ja.
* Schwermütige Klaviermusik *
Der 16-jährige John
steht von allen Seiten unter Druck.
Nur zu seinem leiblichen Vater,
den er selten sieht,
ist die Beziehung locker.
* Virtuose E-Gitarren-Klänge *
Der 47-jährige Roger Bürki
ist Finanzberater
und hat aus zwei gescheiterten
Beziehungen drei Kinder.
John wünscht sich,
beim Vater einzuziehen.
Ich bin in einer kleineren,
aber moderneren Wohnung.
Das ist eine 2-1/2-Zimmerwohnung.
Ich habe jetzt eine Freundin ...
Das ist schwierig.
Es läuft gerade nicht so gut.
Aber ja, ich muss eine neue Wohnung
haben. Eine grössere.
Dann können wir das machen.
Aber das geht
nicht von heute auf morgen.
Hm. Ich muss kurz anrufen.
Ich gehe kurz auf den Balkon.
Auf den Balkon? Ah.
- Mhm.
Also, ich gehe kurz raus.
Der verdammte Scheissdollar
ist am Arsch.
Ist es eine Enttäuschung,
dass du nicht bei ihm wohnen kannst?
Nein, es ist einfach ...
... ein anderer Weg,
den ich gehen muss.
Aber es ist keine Enttäuschung.
Irgendwann
würde ich sowieso allein wohnen.
Es wäre einfach praktischer.
Beim Vater zog John nie ein.
Der heute 28-jährige Single
lebt in einer WG.
Roger Bürki
ist nach Brasilien ausgewandert.
Ich zeige dir mal die Aussicht.
Eigentlich habe ich hier relativ ...
... schnellen Zugang zum Meer.
Zum Strand, ja. Nicht schlecht.
Ja. Kommst du jetzt ...
Oder ... Ähm ...
Hast du mal vor,
nach Brasilien zu kommen?
Je nachdem auch geschäftlich?
- Ja.
Wahrscheinlich
nächstes Jahr oder so.
Wahrscheinlich im August, September.
Aber das ist noch nicht sicher.
Haben Sie rückblickend das Gefühl,
zu wenig Zeit für John
aufgebracht zu haben?
Ähm ...
Diese Vorwürfe macht man sich
als Elternteil natürlich immer.
Dass man zu wenig Zeit für ...
... den Sohn aufbringt.
Ich muss aber auch sagen,
dass ich zwei weitere Kinder hatte.
Das waren insgesamt drei Kinder.
Und auch eine Frau.
Das klappte aber
auch nicht mehr richtig.
Es war eine herausfordernde Zeit.
Und ...
Man tat, was man konnte.
Man versuchte,
alles unter einen Hut zu bringen.
Könnte ich es noch mal machen,
würde ich vieles anders machen.
Was z.B.?- Ich wäre kein Banker,
um mehr Zeit für ihn zu haben.
Ich hätte einen normalen 08/15-Job
als Ingenieur oder so.
Aber das sind Spekulationen.
Gut. Dann ...
- Also, super. Dann ...
Mach es gut. Danke.
- Mach es gut. Schönen Tag.
Dir auch. Tschüss.
Gibt es Momente, in denen
du wütend auf deinen Vater bist?
Hand aufs Herz:
Das gab es auch schon.
Mit dem Älterwerden merkte ich ...
... dass ich da schon
auch ein bisschen etwas ...
... verpasst habe.
Also, ich hatte
Vorteile und Freiheiten ...
Gewisse davon
geniesse ich heute noch.
Ich war auch schon
mit ihm im Ausgang.
Das ist ja auch ...
Das gibt es kaum.
Aber doch ...
Es war auch immer lustig.
Das ist natürlich sehr cool.
Andererseits fehlt einem natürlich
manchmal etwas.
Herbst im Jahr 2010.
Im aargauischen Birr
findet eine Krisensitzung statt.
Es geht um John.
Eingeladen
sind seine geschiedenen Eltern.
Vater Roger Bürki nimmt zum ersten
Mal an einem Elterngespräch teil.
Lehrerin Susanne Tschamper kritisiert
das Verhalten des Jugendlichen.
Wir wissen,
dass er raucht und kifft.
Wer kifft, kann nicht wirklich
lernen und den Kopf nutzen.
(Mutter) Mhm.
- Sie als Eltern:
Haben Sie ihn kontrolliert?
- Ich war sehr passiv.
Zugegeben.
Mein Mann hat etwas mehr
darauf geachtet. - Ja.
Wobei ...
Ich habe erfahren,
was er gemacht hat.
Es erstaunt mich wirklich,
dass es so weit gekommen ist.
John wurde auf dem Schulhaus
von einer Überwachungskamera gefilmt.
Die Eltern erfahren erst jetzt,
was er konkret angestellt hat.
Es ist ganz klar bewiesen:
Er hat die Kamera besprayt.
Er wurde dabei gefilmt.
Das gibt
eine polizeiliche Untersuchung.
Die Schulleitung hat den Jugendlichen
wegen Sachbeschädigung angezeigt.
(Tschamper) Wenn er jetzt
nicht aufpasst, fällt er runter.
Das weisst du, John.
Ich wusste nicht, dass
die Situation so dramatisch ist.
Ich dachte, alles sei in Ordnung.
Keine besonders guten Noten,
aber kein Grund zur Sorge.
Ich muss aber sagen,
dass ich auch nicht
in einer komfortablen Situation bin.
Meine zweite Frau
hat sich von mir getrennt.
Ich habe selber genug Probleme.
Seine Umstände:
kein richtiger Vater zu Hause
und einer,
der etwas hart ansetzt ...
Vielleicht sollte man ihm
für die letzten sechs, sieben Monate
nicht zu viele Steine
in den Weg legen.
(Mutter) Wenn ich mit ihm spreche,
scheint alles in Ordnung zu sein.
Wenn ich frage,
warum er spät zur Schule kam ...
... gibt es keine richtige Antwort.
Nichts Befriedigendes.
Wir haben nicht genug Zeit,
um morgens um 6.55 Uhr
darüber zu sprechen.
Und am Abend mag ich nicht mehr.
Mhm.
Bis morgen.
- Danke.
Schönen Abend.
- Gleichfalls. Ade.
(Lehrerin)
Drei haben schon eine Lehrstelle.
"Wie war es für dich, als deine
Mutter am Elterngespräch weinte?"
Ich glaube, damals ...
Es war mir unangenehm ...
Aber man nimmt es einfach hin.
Ich weiss nicht, wie das hier ist,
ob ihr
auch beim Elterngespräch dabei seid.
Aber an mir ging das damals vorbei.
Wenn ich mir das heute ansehe ...
... ist das anders.
Das geht mir mehr unter die Haut.
Das Elterngespräch
verbesserte die Situation nicht.
Deshalb kam es daheim
zu einer heftigen Auseinandersetzung
mit Johns Stiefvater.
Was genau ist vorgefallen?
Wir hatten Diskussionen
und Missverständnisse ...
Und dann artete es aus.
Ja ...
Gab es wieder Schläge?
Zwei Wochen lang hatte Zoran Sekalec
polizeilich verordnetes Hausverbot,
weil er
den Stiefsohn geschlagen hatte.
Johns Mutter hatte ihn angezeigt.
Nun ist der Kroate wieder daheim.
Kommen Sie da nicht
in Konflikt mit sich selbst?
Einerseits sind Sie sehr religiös
und andererseits gewalttätig
gegenüber Ihrem Stiefsohn.
Das ist eine Diskrepanz.
Sehen Sie das nicht so?
Also, das Stichwort gewalttätig ...
Die Szene ist ja die:
Ich bin kein alkoholisierter Vater
und schlage einfach frustriert rein
oder hasse John.
Das ist nicht das Motiv.
Das Motiv ist, dass ich sehe,
dass Gespräche und ...
... verbindliche Abmachungen
nicht eingehalten werden.
Und dann kam es so weit,
dass ich ihm
mal eine oder mehrere Ohrfeigen gab.
Trotz schwieriger Vergangenheit
trifft sich John heute noch
regelmässig
mit seinem Stiefvater und der Mutter.
Vieles
wurde ausdiskutiert und geklärt.
Ja, ich habe Fehler gemacht.
Als Stiefvater machte ich Druck.
Ich habe einfach ...
... unterschätzt,
dass John sehr sensibel ist ...
... und dass man mit jungen Leuten
halt Geduld haben muss.
Ich glaube heute auch,
dass ich nicht empfänglich war
für die gut gemeinten Ansätze,
die du, Zoran, damals verfolgt hast.
Und das sorgte bei dir
für Unverständnis.
Dann hast du damals Mittel
ergriffen, die für mich ...
... nicht in Ordnung waren.
So schaukelte sich das auf.
Ich habe dich
immer nur als Opfer gesehen,
und Zoran als Täter.
Und ich stand in der Mitte
und wusste nicht ...
... wo ich mich ...
- ... positionieren kann.
... positionieren soll.
Ich glaube,
ich musste auch ein Stück weit ...
... einen Verarbeitungsprozess
machen.
Um zu dem Verhältnis zu kommen,
das wir heute haben.
Also, dass ich wirklich ...
Wie soll ich sagen?
Dass ich weitermachen konnte ...
Ich weiss nicht,
ob ich bewusst vergeben musste.
Vielleicht bin ich einfach
nicht mehr so nahe dran.
Ich glaube, dass Vergeben
eine grosse Rolle gespielt hat.
John hat uns allen vergeben.
Und wir uns selbst.
Ja.
Es hätte auch anders kommen können.
Alle von uns hätten anders ...
Es hätte auch zu einer
absoluten Kontaktauflösung,
also einem Kontaktabbruch
führen können.
Das gibt es auch.
- Das hätte sein können.
Es ist schön und gut,
dass wir die Kurve gekriegt haben.
Und dass wir ein angenehmes,
gesundes Verhältnis haben.- Mhm.
* Nachdenkliche Musik *
Im Mai 2011 sinkt Johns Motivation
in jeder Hinsicht auf den Nullpunkt.
Das wird dem 16-Jährigen
zum Verhängnis.
Nach dem Unterricht
sind er und seine Mutter
von der Schulleitung
zu einem Gespräch geladen.
Ich möchte Sie
zu diesem Gespräch begrüssen.
Das ist für uns alle nicht einfach,
aber wir können es nicht abwenden.
Wir alle wissen, dass
deine Situation nicht einfach ist.
Aber wir können dir
nicht mehr helfen.
Du hast all unsere Hilfestellungen
abgelehnt.
Die Klassenlehrerinnen
waren immer verzweifelter,
weil die Hausaufgaben
hauptsächlich nicht gemacht wurden.
Der Notendurchschnitt
fiel immer tiefer.
Sie gaben sich viel Mühe.
Die Entscheidung
fiel uns sehr schwer.
Aber ...
... es bleibt uns
nichts anderes übrig,
auch weil du v.a. im Klassenlager
relativ offensichtlich
Cannabis konsumiert hast.
Das ist ein ganz klarer Verstoss
gegen diese Regeln.
Und v.a. gegen die Schulregeln.
Darum müssen wir jetzt
die Konsequenzen ziehen:
Es tut uns leid, John ...
... aber nach den Frühlingsferien
können wir dir hier
keinen Platz mehr bieten.
Aber er beendet die Schule, oder?
- Nein.
Im Prinzip hätten wir das
schon lange machen können,
aber wir dachten immer wieder,
wir würden es packen.
Frau Sekalec?
* Schwermütige Musik
aus dem Laptop *
Ich brauche noch eine Unterschrift.
Das ist schon schwere Kost für mich,
den Film heute zu sehen.
Einerseits wegen mir selber,
aber auch wegen der Szenen
mit meinen Eltern und Lehrpersonen.
Das war schon nicht ganz einfach.
Ich glaube, meine Mutter machte in
dieser Zeit einiges durch mit mir.
Ja.
Nur noch drei Wochen hätten gefehlt
bis zum Ende des Schuljahres.
Nun steht er da als Schulversager:
ausgeschlossen vom Unterricht,
ohne Abschluss.
* Schwermütige Musik
aus dem Laptop *
Die ersten zwei Monate nach der
Schule habe ich nicht viel gemacht.
Ich war unterwegs wie vorher,
traf mich mit Freunden
und war viel draussen.
Aber ich machte nicht mehr
als vorher - einfach ohne Schule.
Weil ich wusste, dass bald alle eine
Lehre bzw. Arbeit anfangen werden,
wusste ich,
dass ich auch etwas machen musste.
Ich konnte nicht zu Hause bleiben.
Das wurde auch langweilig.
Also bewarb ich mich
bei einem Burger King.
Ich arbeitete einfach mal
an der Kasse bei Burger King.
Mit 20
absolviert er die Rekrutenschule.
Anschliessend dient er sich
bis zum Oberwachtmeister hoch.
Zum ersten Mal realisiert er,
dass er für sein Leben die Verant-
wortung selbst übernehmen muss.
Nach dem Militär
dachte ich anders als vorher.
Man wird auch etwas reifer
und hat mehr Erfahrung.
Man spricht mit anderen,
lernt sie kennen und was sie machen.
So kam es,
dass ich noch mal einen Job suchte -
und zwar in einem Callcenter.
Es ging darum, etwas zu machen,
Geld zu verdienen
und mich selbst
etwas beschäftigen zu können.
John
besuchte eine kaufmännische Schule
und fand anschliessend
eine Stelle bei einer Versicherung.
Ich lernte, was es heisst,
mit einem Kunden
an einen Tisch zu sitzen
und ihm Dinge zu erzählen.
Zum Thema Versicherung.
Und auch, was es heisst,
sich bei der Arbeit gut anzuziehen.
Seit drei Jahren
arbeitet er bei einem bekannten
Versicherungsunternehmen.
Ein Gespräch
mit einer Kundin steht an.
Ich trage verschiedene Hüte.
Ich bin Teilzeitangestellte
in einem Angestelltenverhältnis.
Ich bin aber
auch Selbstständigerwerbende.
Ich habe in der Vergangenheit
gemerkt,
dass meine momentane private Deckung
teils nicht ausreicht.
Das ist sinnvoll.
Es ist gut, das zu machen.
Ich würde vorschlagen,
dass wir auch direkt schauen,
wo vielleicht sonst noch mögliche
Deckungslücken vorhanden sind.
Es ging jetzt zentral
um den Betriebsrechtsschutz.
V.a.
als selbstständige Unternehmerin ...
... kommen noch Dinge wie Betriebs-
haftpflichtversicherung dazu.
Er ist
ein beliebter Versicherungsberater.
Sein Chef ist mit ihm sehr zufrieden.
Gerade aufgrund seiner Vergangenheit
sei John im Beruf erfolgreich.
Wenn es nur negativ wäre,
müsste man ...
Ich glaube, John wurde als Teenager
sehr missverstanden.
Das ist etwas,
das ihn stark geprägt hat.
Er versucht
in jedem Kundengespräch ...
... sich in die Kundin
oder den Kunden reinzuversetzen,
um ihn oder sie zu verstehen und so
die beste Lösung anbieten zu können.
Und den Kunden oder die Kundin
in allen Lebenssituationen
zu begleiten.
Das ist stark ausgeprägt bei ihm,
weil er selber Missverständnisse
durchgemacht hat.
Darum kann er sich jetzt so gut
in sein Gegenüber reinversetzen.
Ein spezieller Moment.
John trifft nach Jahren
seine ehemalige, inzwischen pensio-
nierte Lehrerin Susanne Tschamper.
Es freut mich mega.
- Ebenso.
Nach längerer Zeit. Stefan.
Mit dabei sind auch Stefan Widmer
und Cindy Fersch.
Alle drei besuchten vor zwölf Jahren
dieselbe Abschlussklasse.
Du siehst gut aus.
- Danke.
Merci. Das gebe ich gerne zurück.
- Alle sind noch gleich, nur älter.
(Tschamper) Man erkennt alle noch.
Gehen wir rein und schauen,
wo wir waren?
Ich halte die Tür auf.
Danke schön.
- Bitte.
Seit Ende der Schulzeit
ist es der erste Besuch
im ehemaligen Klassenzimmer.
Es ist nostalgischer als erwartet.
Da kommen Erinnerungen auf.
- Aha, so.
Biologieprüfungen und ...
- Franzwörterprüfungen ...
... die Karte ...
Ja, wirklich.
- Da fühle ich mich angesprochen.
Jetzt sind wir
im Ernst des Lebens angekommen.
Voll im Berufsleben.
- Wir haben Erfahrungen gemacht.
Ja, diverse.
Wahrscheinlich dachten wir dazumal
nicht, dass wir hier landen.
Stefan Widmer lernte Strassenbauer
und arbeitet
noch heute auf diesem Beruf.
Cindy Fersch
ist Fachfrau Kinderbetreuung.
Zurzeit macht sie die Berufsmatura
und will danach
Psychologie studieren.
(Tschamper) Am frohsten
und glücklichsten bin ich darüber,
dass John den Weg gefunden hat,
denn damals war die Situation
wirklich sehr unbefriedigend -
und zwar für alle.
Am meisten aber für dich,
das ist klar.
Für uns als Schule - wir dachten:
"Das ist ja keine Lösung."
"Das bringt John nichts."
Wir stiessen an unsere Grenzen.
Es wurde plötzlich
extrem ruhig im Klassenzimmer.
John fehlte schon, aber es war ...
Man hatte viel versucht und gemacht
und wollte ihm helfen ...
Mich hat das auch belastet.
Ich fand es
eine schlimme Situation für ihn.
Ich wollte ihm helfen,
so gut es ging.
War es richtig, John drei Wochen
vor Schulende rauszuwerfen?
Das klingt so dramatisch.
Also für ihn
war es wohl schon dramatisch.
Ich sagte damals:
"Richtig ist das nicht."
Aber ihn zu behalten,
war auch nicht richtig.
Es war einfach konsequent.
Irgendwann
mussten wir die Konsequenzen ziehen.
Wir konnten John
nicht immer nur sagen ...
Oder wem auch immer.
Es gab viele andere Johns.
Und auch Mädchen.
Da musste man eine Grenze aufzeigen.
Und wenn die nie respektiert wird,
muss man handeln.
Sonst darf man nichts sagen.
Das ist ... Wie siehst du das heute?
Einerseits
stimme ich dem absolut zu.
Ich selber bin auch dieser Meinung.
Glücklicherweise
war das nie ein Problem.
Es wurde mir nie zum Verhängnis -
das ist nicht selbstverständlich.
Aber es gibt
natürlich auch die Meinung,
dass man das für die
letzten paar Wochen irgendwie ...
... hätte handeln können.
- Ja.
Vor der Schulklasse
im sankt-gallischen Buchs
spricht er zum Abschluss
über seine Karrierepläne.
Mein jüngster Erfolg ist ...
... die VBV-Prüfung.
Das ist die erste berufsspezifische
Prüfung für den Beruf,
den ich heute mache,
also in Versicherung und Vorsorge.
Ich habe die Prüfungsergebnisse
erst gerade Ende November erhalten.
Mit ...
... guten Noten -
zu meinem Erstaunen.
In der schriftlichen Prüfung
hatte ich eine 5
und in der mündlichen eine 5,5.
Das war für mich
ganz anders als in der Schulzeit,
so einen Erfolg zu haben.
Ja, das ist der Stand heute.
Was in Zukunft passieren kann -
ich habe zwei Bilder hier:
Das eine ist Psychologie.
Ich überlege mir, ob ich noch mal
die Schulbank drücken soll,
um die Matura nachzuholen
und dem nachzugehen ...
... was mich bisher
doch am meisten fasziniert.
Das ist eine Option:
Ein Studium zu versuchen.
Und die zweite Option -
das ist auch eher ein Gedankenspiel:
vielleicht selbstständig zu werden.
In der Schule
wollte John Bürki nicht lernen,
aber danach verstand er die Lektion,
die ihm das Leben gab.
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
puretype gmbh - 2023